pour terminer ce top 5 des bugs tud ar
tête je vais vous parler d'un site
incroyable qui propose des services de
la mafia albanaise regard des pièces ça
ça va faire du bruit c'est fini l'époque
du tout neuf en a eu peur du monde
pendant trop longtemps la maintenance et
au monde avoir peur de nous et mal car
on va les descentes c'est que ça l'est
c'est à dire t'as jamais eu mais bien
sûr que j'ai tué par la flak temps
maintenant vous tous nous a grandi en
afghanistan les principaux échos tel
qu'un première fois s'est divisée après
facile je vais vous butez bande
d'enculés si je vous dis le data ou va
faire quoi c'est eux c'est possible pour
qu'il me cherche flo
enfin métier passion tu te rends compte
de la chance qu'on a au contraire on tue
des gens ou raquettes déjà
je vais prendre la tête au lof pour la
sentence que le dos légumes camus et
armés jusqu'aux dents on est vraiment
débordé en ce moment et oui à trân thê
vinh a
24 heures pour trouver une solution ou
démentir patrick alley non
je suis un gros coup là
les gangsters albanais
arrête de faire des films
on l'apprenait sur mello
c'est du très bon là
[Musique]
plusieurs
s'en passe des choses dans votre bled en
a bien fait de venir